oder was kannst du irgendwas keine waffe
weil ich den stadtgarten in die dafür
nimmt die wahre alter bist du alles aber
papa bin ich live h da sind wir live mit
dem lieben regenzeit thomas wir müssen
echt diese diese gute gleiter knüpfen
gewährt bekommt es nervt mich jedes mal
so nein die super geil oder kleine
shotgun ribery aber den japan gilt der
wir glaube ich auf jeden fall ihren los
gewünscht
ich habe in einer gated nein ich bin ja
kommt auch der kommt hoch rui hinter die
hinter dem internetzeitalter alter ehre
was kommt schnell wir müssen uns jetzt
ein baum
hier ist noch viel zu viel los aber wir
müssen jetzt die ruhige kugel schieben
wir haben 1300 zuschauer bringen
danke nochmal für das retten gerade hier
ja also näher in meinem leben allgemein
hier richtig wollen wir jetzt mal ein
bisschen außerhalb gehen also ich weiß
nicht nein
ja manchmal kriegt dem westen sind
wirklich ja aber man kriegt ihn schlecht
das nur indem man stirbt behältnisse
richtung richtung es so ich habe einen
gekittet einmal die wahl gesagt gesagt
wenn sie kommen bitten
ich habe nochmal eingeht ich habe
absolut keine munition dicke das ist
echt krank also ich bin im arsch da oben
alles offen dach sind auch noch welche
rolle ich bin komme ich mache eine
reaktion war ja also aber ich glaube es
ist uns geschrieben und da war noch kein
killer ball tatsächlich haben es war ein
witz ist ja disco dominanz habe ich
jetzt bestimmt und zwölf gesuche
das hatte ich auch schon mal irgendwie 5
ja genau die machen dann alle sogar 60
70 egal ich gebe mich gleich mal revue
lauter als ob wir das nochmal hören darf
sie laut trittin ist viel zu laut junge
war junge hatte obwohl er eigentlich
beides also wieso dann immer am anfang
junge damit man es schon hat man 2000
zuschauer geisteskrank also echt über
solche langweilig ist es wenn sie sagen
weil die gerundete doch wenn man stirbt
gleich am anfang weil man nix drauf hat
bleibt einfach bei mir thomas dann
kriegen wir schon hin
witzel einer hundehütte dort läuft wie
die ganzen leute fragen mich immer wie
das ist heute erst mal und zweitens das
haus nimmt so um die kiste im
dachgeschoss ich gehe nach unten
ich schaffe es nicht nach oben aber
genau auch hier und mal dort war ich
gerne oben jan päßler das ist eine gute
waffe und das absolut haben will
ich weiß ja noch ein bisserl ist es gut
man hat doch einfach mal hier sind
gegner bei uns würde ich ja gerade die
leute schreiben chatten besser als du
inhalte also war das so ist ich finde es
eigentlich dass man jetzt ein fallschirm
hat nicht viel besser sah es nach der
wende war ist kaufmann geht schon jetzt
aber als ich hab halt einfach ja die
gibt auch die schott gelegt da drehen
junge dafür würde
hast du brauchst schild ist ja du hast
gelogen bisschen angeli jedoch ein
zweiter top da oben nämlich nicht auf ok
doch dann kommt schon wenn das meine
mama macht alle mit ein euro gespendet
holy moly anthem eine warme mahlzeit
geisteskrank viele leute wissen dass ich
absolut nichts verdienen
das ist so dreist was wir jetzt das ist
echt eine lüge für den genug konzept
mitnehmen kann mit mitnehmen
weihnachtsfeiertag mir noch mal zwei
euro gespendet geil es gibt jetzt
insgesamt 33 euro man nicht also ein
dünner
mission geschafft hat einer das ist
nicht gerade einfach deine videos
schneiden sollte und nicht live stream
eigentlich hatte das wochenende wird
müssen sie gerade was machst du weißt du
des bestandes ich glaube einfach gar
nicht heute ich mache live stream video
schneide alter noch mal 180 heike knief
hat mir geraten euro gespendet weil ich
noch nie was als ob guten kaffee märz
weiter wobei uns mittlerweile kann ich
dir sogar dünner aus spendieren ok
jetzt hat man das nicht so also nicht in
köln waren auch noch wenn man du bist
wie ich halte aber uns geht ich habe
mich noch mal geht er ist ledig sein
vater thomas noch bis zum winter so
vater register gar nicht ich habe ihm
ging es halt der andere bei anderen habe
ich habe den ich hatte nur begeistert
ich hab den übeltäter kevin ausgeliehen
ausgehen kommen aus der praxis bald und
jetzt wenn du den leuten über die
abgeben kannst du dich auch noch im dc
haben dann steht dem dorf gar nichts im
wege der junge mann
würdest du irgendwo ins neue büro lassen
wieso nicht weil ich angst hätte dass
der mann toten körper führen falls er
darum ringen noch mal zwei jahre vom
leid weiter holy moly übertreibt nicht
für aufkauft
zum beispiel kann ich was
oder was kannst du irgendwie hat keine
waffe weil ich den stadtgraben in die
worte von ihm die waffe alter bist du
eine flasche hörst du mich jetzt wieder
ja weil ich ja das ist weil mein
richtiges mikrofon abgekauft ist lieber
thomas kann man sich auf seinem kanal
das mandat zu bewerben
also ich weiß jetzt selber nie was
moderat man machen was man getrieben
das ist eine gute frage ich bin tot
das problem ist dass meine maus echt
nicht so dass das leck so wie es ja das
ist ein bisschen wie ist keine außerdem
ist es halt immer was anderes als es
wird wieder nach unten thomas vor der
kiste
jahrhundert da ist eine aufgabe aller
hast du eine parkkarte liegen lassen
derweil mit wasser bewundert wer also
problemlos machbar nationen also ich
lasse immer die guten was hältst du noch
danken den einen mini den und werde es
auch geben können
ich habe dann auch gut dass über den
angewohnheit das meine ich ja das war ja
naja hab ich ja also man muss ja auch
nicht einmal das nehmen was man will ja
ja wunderschön gehabt habe und ich werde
nochmal thomas kann online ich muss man
schnell die so eine runde forderte
liebsten spielen damit eigentlich gibt
es gar nicht so groß weil mein vater hat
er selber youtuber und irgendwie hast du
für mich also kater gute kann also nicht
leicht zu bekommen ja ja
hier wird auch keinen das ist das
problem ist ja die dreifach sage auf den
baum auf dem baum
er ist hinter dir
das ist so mein gott war das erst mal
was denn es werden ja da hätte ich jetzt
das hätte ich nicht gerechnet und
hersteller weißt du noch das heißt denn
auch das video als ich deine liebe
klappt das auch nennenswerten dass du
immer gesagt ist das parlament anhören
musste wirklich sehr wohl
bist du weg auch ne jahrzehnt was klingt
ihr die sonne ist absolut drin im haus
hier ja absolut nicht nicht jetzt
wirklich gar kein sport aktuell nicht
macht aber eigentlich sehr gerne unsere
zuschauer müssen nicht besonders gerne
und es kamen so viele andere spiele raus
ich mag wählt beispielsweise gerne und
blackout natürlich auch da bin ich
aktuell ja fast durch es hat mir golden
score für dich auch nicht was geben
möchte gold für dich das ist mir egal
was sage ich dir hatte beim gegner
vielleicht jetzt ja entspannt ich fand
dich erwartet preis leistung
nein das war es von vorn mit ri die an
der förde also ich gehe davon aus dass
er das nicht überlebt glaub ich spiele
jetzt noch ein bisschen disco dominanz
also ich bin weiter ich habe zweimal
gemacht perfekt auf das glück nicht
lade ich mir gleich ein kumpel von mir
einen alten
[Musik]